all right so here's the story youtube
just changed the layout i had no idea
what was going on my browser stopped
working on youtube only and i thought my
internet connection was out or something
something weird was going on i couldn't
get onto youtube to comment on my latest
video then i realized that was the only
site that wasn't working wikipedia
worked fine new york times worked fine
it was just that one website youtube.com
that wasn't working then 15 seconds
later it's back up again and i go to
youtube.com and i look at a video and
it's all screwed up i'm like what
happened to the youtube layout why is it
different or
something is different about it yes
youtube did some changes there i thought
my browser screwed up honestly i was i
use it in safari i use it in firefox it
is an opera i use an internet explorer i
use it in chameleon i use it in like six
web browsers and it was the same in
every single one youtube changes the
layout again let me give you a peek
so yeah first of all here's what i did i
went and opened up safari and it wasn't
working for a while and then what do you
know you open up safari this is just my
youtube page right here thank you to all
my subscribers then you know what you go
to a video to watch it
and i'll just pause it here but you look
under it look at that what what did they
do it's it's different you see the
ratings it's it's just it's boring
i thought i i personally thought my
browser screwed up but you know what
youtube changed the layout again
how could they do this to me how could
they change it without telling me i'm
obviously kidding but seriously comment
below do you like the new youtube layout
does it look good bad kind of okay no
big deal
i just thought it was weird that they
changed it and during those few seconds
where youtube did not work it's probably
that the whole world was just like why
isn't youtube working so i commented on
a video and those people were like yeah
it is different so i was like well it's
not just me so yeah comment below what
do you think of the new youtube layout
good bad medium
tell me what you think peace
you